I just came out of the session a cold
powerful storytelling where the star was
came and said he was a really nice
experience may concern him like he don't
even trust the house with the girls or
their dear ones English manor in Japan
so after visiting them in the moment of
the worst moments he promised a monkey
way to do another movie because that's
all she does and he already shows him
the movie he had promised so he told
this story and then a quorum of a
Japanese also group died in an
earthquake and was born with the first
big tsunami and so it was a very torture
he said he's a contribution from the
ground zero the wrong people was
moderated by Jeff fathers and it worked
with the producer of 60 minutes way an
imagined community took John why not
beautiful back today from a radio
station in each area it also explains
how she just reserved I telling stories
and people to make a bit personal very
touching if we listen to one of the
story she but that by the way this the
subject prepare journalism was herself
the mother who identified the toxin
abuse American people and a almost a
mouse the cellist he told us why she
plays the backs in she does in his
channel in total darkness why does he
look for a new in a media tour for a
classic it's very interesting the way he
talked about you can finally eat tomato
sauce and Mexican right here I spoke but
I think it's a power of storytelling
they importance of this feeling any kind
of stories and how they've always given
us a meaning of ourselves as a chef at a
sad story this place they are there also
to not only took us away from bed but
also they make the talent in there are
ways to engage in political man hostage
in Mexico and it is very small summarize
local bus yeah